gives your child a head start
by improving their english skills
with a world class course at
british like
celine as a world expert in
teaching english
we understand exactly what
your child needs for him or her to
operate  its potential
we can create the perfect formula
for your child's needs
in one of our centers or online by
offering diplomas recognized
around the world
our courses are structured so that
your child progresses it feels fun
interactive and effective for all
children whatever their level
our teachers are passionate and
train continuously to teach
children and adolescents hills is to
develop your
child's skills in English all in a
modern and comfortable environment
through online resources and
interactive courses
we offer world-class educational tools
designed to assess
and encourage  your
child's learning so wherever you are in the
world
we have a solution to
learn English well will give your
child the confidence they need at every
stage of their life and open them up to a world
of opportunities
in our centers  or online get
your child a boost
from today with the world's English experts